Okay,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina
three
or you're probably turned down.
Did you do that on purpose?
A purpose.
So it's very exciting.
Uh,
if you don't know what we're doing,
what do you mean?
You're pointing at me like I would do it.
That's your fault.
Just turn your headphones up now they are up.
Okay,
there,
there.
We're doing the podcast live brass balls,
beach,
Florida at the West Palm Improv
August 23rd.
It's going to be awesome.
It is getting full.
Just so people know.
We will be meeting everyone after the show.
People have asked us that.
He didn't say anything about that.
Well,
I will be personality champ.
Actually say probably shit.
No Way.
You can really make a determination for yourself.
If you're at that show
personality champ.
Um,
make sure you,
uh,
you get your tickets.
Also the Irvine Improv.
We're doing your mom's house live October 8th.
It's going to go down.
Don't sweat it.
This is the one we rescheduled.
If you did have tickets to the last one,
they did not transfer.
That's something we just found out.
Um,
and the reason that they didn't transfer is because they're dumb,
but wow,
why wouldn't you do that?
So it's pretty sensible and refunded people.
You just have to rebate and that's what they're doing.
So,
October 8th,
Irvine Improv your mom's house live.
Um,
I am shooting a special September 16th in Denver.
Uh,
the first show is sold out.
The second show has about 150 tickets left.
So if you want to go,
this is probably the last week there'll be available,
a couple of shows that have been added.
Just so you know,
I'm doing the Brayer Improv for one night,
September 13th.
So that's two nights or three nights before I shoot this special.
I'm doing the Fox theater in Oakland,
uh,
two nights before the special.
And,
uh,
the week before I'm in Nebraska,
Midwest city and Springfield,
Missouri,
all leading up to the special.
After that,
the,
uh,
my tour continues.
If you go to Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour,
you can see all the dates there.
Toronto,
Anarbor,
Indianapolis.
It just goes on and on.
Of course,
New York City is now on sale,
g Dork titties.
Um,
I always feel it necessary to explain to the Toronto people that because of the
way that the,
uh,
festival set up the links,
when you go to my page,
if you go to violet,
Toronto tickets and you hit like fine tickets,
it,
it finds you a festival pass,
you actually have to scroll down and go headliner ticket and that's the
individual tickets to my show.
It's just really annoying.
So,
uh,
I've had to explain people on Instagram and on Twitter,
you know,
a hundred times how to do that.
It's just a,
something they didn't really think through.
Uh,
this song,
by the way,
is easy produced by Chris Rhythm about that prism for them.
Yeah.
You said Nebraska unthinking nerd Brasco yeah.
I don't know.
There's a better one out there,
but nerd breasts and their breasts.
Dude,
that was horrible.
You have no idea what you just did to people.
That was horrible.
Why would you do that into them?
That was horrible because I've never done it before.
Almost wanting to try it completely.
Blew it out,
Sam.
Sorry God,
I just wanted to see what that felt like.
Alright.
I've never off.
Why
did you do that to me?
I've never sneezed on this show.
1 million people.
Just ask that question.
Uh,
I know you are.
I love you.
Where are you going to be?
Alright,
I'm hog tits with you.
The 23rd and West Prom.
Perry Palm Bruh.
Bitch.
September 22nd and 23rd St Louis tits.
Moms are at hearing them comedy club and then October 3rd Noshville Nashville,
Tennessee.
Yeah.
That's good.
Nashville,
Tennessee.
That's Amy's is come on you club.
That's good.
October 4th.
Charlotte,
North Carolina.
It's a great,
it's course.
It's Charlotte at the comedy zone and then October 8th I'm with you doing why mh
live in sperm via is Charlotte a one nighter?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
October for it.
Okay.
Is that okay with you?
Yeah,
of course.
Tickets are now@christinaponline.com or you can still do thousand ranch.
That's still good to do.
What?
I did.
Go and see Christina doing stand up yet.
Now we're talking.
Come on dude.
Um,
what are you trying to do to me that's exciting.
That's my,
the the special.
My special,
the title and my special.
Do you like big tits?
Good.
Show me how those big tits fart.
Okay,
good name Mushy purples.
You are voting for mushy purple.
That was hard voting for it.
Yeah.
They age into the managers don't like that one.
No,
I like it a lot.
Do like big debts.
You like big dates do lie big debts.
That's great.
Oh Man.
Okay.
Right.
Good.
All
right.
Oh,
I added a second show in Fart.
Go.
I'm going to Fargo where they filmed the TV show is your favorite show.
I know that.
I'm going to do it.
I added a second show there,
so just letting people know.
Is that in North Dakota?
Yeah,
I guessed.
You know that.
Wow.
Are you branding yourself?
All I know is like,
it's definitely not la so I don't have to care.
There you go.
I do want to be knowledgeable of the world.
Good attitude.
You did Amazon right?
Didn't do moms on.
Please shop through our Amazon banner.
It's very easy to do.
All you do is go to your mom's house,
podcast.com and you do the shopping you would normally do on Amazon.
After you click our banner,
it gives a little kickback to the show.
We also have a UK version and we have a Canadian version and Canadia and
Canadia.
You can shop through our amazon.ca banner and it supports the show.
Canada's not la,
but I still like it.
It's your birthplace Ontario,
Windsor,
Godwin's or native.
She brought me out and try.
I know.
It's really funny.
I did.
Yeah,
you go.
Proud winds are native and I was wearing a Canadian Tuxedo on that show.
That was really fun.
That was a lot of fun.
It's always fun to do.
Canadia.
I actually am most looking forward if I could be honest.
I'm really looking forward to shooting this special and you just spilled on your
big tits and I'm looking forward to shooting this special obviously in Denver,
but for the rest of the year,
I think I'm most looking forward to my Toronto date.
Yeah.
t.is an amazing city.
I really called it that.
I coined that phrase data and now they call it,
it's embarrassing.
All right,
here we go.
Let's start the show.
All the places on your calendars are places you want to go to.
I liked doing my tour.
I'm saying a most,
I love the city of Toronto.
It's going to be exciting for me and my cousin Bree,
Bree might come.
Oh you're kidding.
Yeah.
Is,
is there food in Toronto?
Oh my God.
He's going to ask me so many things.
Are you,
do you know what time you're checking in and then do you know,
um,
what,
uh,
are you going to go downstairs now?
What time is it?
Should I go with,
is there,
can I stand back and get out of his seat?
Can I,
can I also do it and then after,
do you want me to be there?
And then how are you getting to the airport,
which was gate where you think you're going to get something to drink before
you,
do you think the foods too spicy in Toronto or will they have items on the menu
that don't have spice?
I have to wash your hands after cause I don't want to get spice in my cat's eyes
when I pet my can I have the enzymes to break down all that spice.
That's true.
You know my parents were the opposite of your parents.
Like where's your parents explain things to you and they were like,
they take the time and my family there was a do not ask questions.
Policy.
Yeah.
It was always like don't ask,
just don't ask.
So I learned to be very self reliant that way.
I don't ask questions anymore.
All right.
Here we go.
Dig a big stinky shit after I go.
I don't use Twitter for I flushed the toilet.
I did my hand as getting here.
Yeah.
Three,
three roughly.
And then flush again.
We'll dip.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Don't
bring it
to your mom's house.
Shoot.
Christina pushes.
It seems
so rude,
dude.
A white guy.
We were.
Thanks Trevor.
When they came out a ball Sacramento this weekend,
the full charge was with me.
Oh always.
Fantastic.
Always fantastic.
We were hanging out and randomly we heard two guns and roses songs just like in
restaurants and stuff.
And we were talking about like,
can you imagine what it was like in their heyday to be slash on stage during one
of those solos and your face is melting off from the drugs you did backstage and
you're just like,
you don't even have to think to play your solo and it's a stadium.
It's like 80,000 people she was going like,
and you're so fucking high,
you know,
and the energy and like it's so crazy they probably to tell you when,
when the show is over there like,
hey man,
it's over now.
He's like,
what?
He was saying,
uh,
full charge said he read slashes book.
Yeah.
And that,
you know,
they used to get so fucked up just drinking the handles of Jack and doing heroin
and I'm laying on that.
He a one time he called somebody in a hotel and he was like,
where are we?
And they go,
We're in Tokyo.
He goes,
shut the fuck up.
And they go look out the window.
He looked out the window,
he was like,
Oh shit it is Tokyo.
He had no idea where he was.
O m g O M G for real plan.
Those hot licks?
Yeah.
Not on the road.
Is that what they call those hot licks or they get to ours.
The hot legs
think such a dad where I know,
could you imagine also the rate at which those guys were probably getting laid
to?
No know their outcome.
There's no car,
there's no way.
There's no kind of way.
And even that guy slash I wasn't a huge,
I was just not a huge fan of those dudes.
I was listening to bow house and you know,
whatever.
But yeah,
his face was totally covered with hair right here on the,
I like on the bridge of your nose and the hair cover,
the face and the cigarette.
It was just hanging out of his mouth.
I mean he just looked fucked up constantly.
I don't know if he was,
but he definitely looked that way,
but he could shred right talent.
I just remember I was telling him,
I remember that,
you know people would always talk about guitar players and I'm not a guitar
player,
but I would always hear the conversations about the greatest and it would always
be people would talk about BB king,
Eric Clapton,
always people and Hendrix.
But I remember when when at least when I was listening to those songs at first I
would be like,
is this not a bad motherfucker?
Because it sure sounds like it to me the way that those solos and spellings
outlets were shred apart man.
I mean he really did.
He destroyed on this amazing look.
Nobody,
very few people didn't like that bat.
I was gone.
I was like hardcore God than,
and I knew all their songs because they had played them in grocery stories and
shit and they definitely still hold up for sure.
Shoe songs are like you could put it on,
it's,
it's a solid,
did you have a GNR shirt?
No,
I wasn't.
I wasn't a GNR shirt guy,
but I definitely had those.
I had the tape cause that's still like one of the best.
I remember for a football it was,
it was one of the pregame tapes.
They play on the overhead system.
Welcome to the jungle and and and also in the weight room.
So like whenever we had,
I mean that came on.
It still comes on and you're like,
fuck it.
Let's do this.
Crack some fucking skulls.
When you hear that music definitely welcome
jungle.
Yeah.
Wow.
I don't
think I've ever heard you do that voice and I never want to hear it again.
Was it as good as my sneeze earlier or worse?
Like what was more,
the snooze was terrible.
His nuts.
Another person.
Axl Rose's voices also.
So crazy.
Crazy maze.
I do think he still can sing like that.
He's old.
No,
I don't think he could sing just like that,
but I think it's probably pretty good because that there is,
there is such thing as after a certain point.
There's certain voices that just you can't carry,
can't hit the notes she used,
Whitney couldn't,
I don't think Aretha Franklin can hit the notes she hit in the seventies like
it's just like
you age.
I liked Perry for ELLs voice a lot from James and he's got a great voice.
He's another one that I don't think it sounds like anybody else.
It's amazing.
It's super unique.
It's true.
Yeah.
It's a weird one.
But axles was like so famous and nobody,
if somebody else,
there's songs where another singer can sing the song.
You're like yeah that's,
that's that song.
But if someone else sings guns [inaudible] roses songs,
it doesn't sound like no that,
that's a special unique thing.
A group of people in the space and,
and place and
everything can't replicate now car cause I grew up even when I was,
I grew up in La and I remember when that ban hit GNR cause they were like a
sunset strip bad.
It was fucking pandemonium.
Dude's like,
cause I used to go to the Roxy.
My stepmom liked of all things hash and music,
like heavy metal,
heavy metal is huge.
When those guys came out.
So we would go down to the Roxy and see bands play and that they were just the
biggest thing,
man.
Those guys,
you couldn't escape them.
Did you see them play in a small venue?
I don't think so.
No.
No,
but I remember pirate radio was this thing in La was like Hessian radio station
and they played them and it was a big scene here.
It must have been so crazy to be like,
oh yeah,
I saw guns and roses.
It fucking,
yeah,
on sunset.
And then the next year,
where do you see them?
Oh,
there are dodger stadium right now.
Yeah,
my,
well,
our friend Alan who does our hair,
he's like,
yeah,
so if we can,
Jane's addiction on sunset.
And I saw clicking GNR he saw,
he's a little bit older than us,
so he saw that stuff
all for sure.
He's all fucking saw the pixies like in 1986 he looks good for his age,
doesn't he?
I start to pay attention to that so much more now.
I saw something like some guy died and it was on his bio in the said 53 I'm
like,
it's good.
It does do,
it looks 80 yeah.
There's people who just,
you know,
look,
you're lucky because your pops.
He looks great.
He looks fantastic.
71 looks great.
My mother actually aged very well til we'll see what happens here.
But none of that shit.
They both looked okay.
You're set up for success.
Now this actually means it's all on you
stay off the heroin.
Yeah.
Now you see it all the time.
I mean I'm talking to people and then a Rogan just turned 50 I think he looks
amazing.
Looks Great.
Really takes care of himself though.
Right?
So that is the key is an age where you can look 40 or you can look 90 50 is like
a really,
you follow one side or the other?
Oh yeah.
Well 40 is when you hit a wall.
That's,
that's when you either you go hard on maintenance.
No,
I'm in my thirties I'm like thinking about what it would be like,
shut up.
I just don't know.
Hate you so much.
How much more until your forties I don't know.
I can't add that high.
It's still a while though.
What's going to happen?
What's it like up there?
Actually I was already thinking that how next year I still won't turn 40 what
would that be like?
I don't know.
I like bringing my four I like 41 it's awesome.
It's fucking great because you don't give a fuck.
I didn't give a fuck in my thirties now I give even less fucks in my forties
fucking don't care.
I do like that process of of living and aging.
People don't realize it really happens where as the years go by,
you really are like,
I don't give a fuck.
Every year it's a little more,
you don't care about something.
It's not that you don't care about everything,
that you care about certain things and then the rest just disappeared.
Realize how insignificant and not important things are.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's just like we know when you're in middle school you
care so much about,
oh my God,
where did that person think?
If I wear these brown shoes and you think it's so important and you,
you make sure that like you,
you don't have those shoes on you like you think that that's someone else's
focus.
You know,
and then,
I don't know,
2030 years later you're like,
I can go,
you know of shit into like something to be carrying.
What I wore and not to be a shameless plug or right now,
but on that steep bro.
That is a lot of what I talk about on that show about life and the nature of it
and get and part of getting your life too is like you,
you learn to focus your fox.
Really.
It's like that book man.
Subtle art of not giving a fuck.
It was funny cause I,
I bought this book,
I've been reading it and then I go you're going to love this and then you're
like,
oh my God,
oh blah blah blah blah.
I'll talk about all the time.
I love your voice.
I love the,
you're a girl talk voice.
Cause I hear you speak on how I talk.
That's how your sisters taught.
No it's no,
that's exactly why you talk
about your boyfriend here.
Take a big stinky shit.
Flush the toilet.
Let's get in here.
Yeah.
Do you want to describe his,
uh,
his gear is attire.
Uh,
let's say he's on the non binary spectrum.
Yeah.
I mean the shirt is torn open so that half of his chest is written as a torn
shirt.
And it says sexy Vegan and then Vegan on the arm.
He's vegans either tattooed or it's written in humongous permanent marker.
And then it's over the eye.
Oh,
and the other four on his eyebrow and he's got like those,
what are those gauges or something and his ears and um,
yeah,
it looks Bluetooth or it looks lean.
He's definitely definitely eats right now we know so he doesn't use paper,
but I thought this was interesting.
Listening to hiss.
I flush,
flush
tip,
get this six times and then sometimes do more around here.
First of all,
I want to point out that you know,
he's big on obviously not using the paper.
He's already flushed three or four times.
So He's wasting water.
So he's trading paper waste for waterway.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
we'll see.
That's gross.
But the fact remains set for library science and smells.
There's no one putting smell and everyone else's,
but you could smell from like at least a foot away.
You go like or
honor and then you could smell a mining camp.
My smells delicious.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Did you just see what I saw and eyebrows what?
There are no eyebrows.
They're shaved and pencil.
Their PR,
their it in like that crazy guy that used to live in the rampart division at the
bus stop.
Are you suggesting that this guy's not mentally fit?
What's going on with these Vegan do fee convit shine.
So they love to identify vegans can't shut the fuck up about it.
That's the anomaly.
That's one lane of it.
But this is also like a little crazy and it's become an identity.
Like when the Diet becomes an identity and the look,
I get it.
It's a candid,
I'm licking your balls are your penis or anus or something?
Go ahead.
You can pretend you can pretend that permission Telford fucking hate that guy.
No,
I don't hate,
I don't want to put out there that I,
I,
I do not hate vegans.
I don't,
I just think when you identify with any diet so much you have to advertise it.
It's a little weird.
Steve's really into it.
He goes deep and it's caught hold with his bare hand.
Hold on,
jumped over that.
We got our weddings ass with his bare hands and the toilet water and then it
goes deep and his asshole.
Well,
let me,
let me tell you why I'm not so opposed to it because the tushy yeah,
and the bid day use the toilet water that's in the tank,
which is using his hand though gene.
Right.
But it's all,
it's all tight.
I'm not on the same.
Okay.
You know.
Well,
yeah,
but you use,
okay,
let's you use your hand to wash your ass hole in the shower.
Okay,
bear.
You don't use a washcloth and shit when I do it.
It's not a shitty ass hole.
It's already very clean butthole.
I know.
I'm just trying to give him the benefit of the doubt.
That's all I used to use to entire rolls of toilet paper.
I have to go on it just gets it.
Wait cleaner.
No toilet.
Paper's not on the house or no self.
You don't want it.
Don't want it.
Don't hit you on.
Oh no soap too.
Right now.
Wait a minute.
That's just not sanitary for China because he's going to get the poopy on his
hands and his mouth.
Oh,
you need soap buddy.
No,
he's not into it.
Then the ball.
Why not the soap?
It's Vegan.
There's Vegan soap.
There's gotta be Vegan stuff like Dr Bronner's or whatever that hippie soap at
wholefoods.
Oh no,
man,
there's gotta be Vegan soap.
Know those guys.
He's really,
he's big on pushing his,
uh,
he goes,
you don't like it.
There's no toilet paper.
There's no soap.
Don't let the door hit you on the way out.
Ah,
I have problems with that in the past.
No,
I,
I actually think there's a lack of people visiting his home is my guess.
I don't think that there's a lot of visitors at all.
No.
I think when they go,
Hey,
did you shave your eyebrows and write vegan on your forehead?
And then they go,
maybe I won't come over.
Actually,
I think that happened,
but the thing is,
is that he's a fairly attractive human.
He's not like the other animal and got to clean ass hole.
He said it doesn't even smell.
He doesn't use soap on it.
So how clean candidate he said,
and it doesn't smell.
I trust him.
I don't trust him.
Okay.
I don't trust you need soap.
Hey,
do you want to hear some good news and to septic?
So much horrible news these days.
Oh my gosh.
Some good news.
The chubby chaser took our advice.
Remember that girl?
Yeah,
she wrote in.
Yeah.
How do I go?
She writes Hello Jean.
I wrote to you about a month ago asking advice on how to approach a Chubby guy I
was interested in and just wanted to give you a followup.
I took your advice and happy to say it worked out.
I made the first move like you suggested,
and we went out last weekend.
All your suggestions about reassert reassert reassurance and physicality were
spot on as he seemed to loosen up as the night went on.
I also went out of my way to make sure that night would be my cheat day.
So I didn't come up with a stuck up bitch.
Food's not good.
We have plans this weekend again,
and I can't wait to get to know him better.
Uh,
would he ever date his mom?
Does he like Moose Soup?
Maybe he loves watching studio g clips.
Guests.
We'll find out.
Thanks again.
Hitler.
Your adoring fart mistress Brittany.
How about that's fantastic.
Yeah,
you guys are doing good.
Glad to hear it.
It's so excite.
Good for you.
I hope you guys get along.
I hope it's a longterm mommy.
Yeah.
You find your genes.
I hope you do.
It's really great.
Really Great.
Everybody finds their jeans.
You know,
it's interesting.
Last night,
uh,
we were watching billions.
We were in bed.
So obsessed with that show.
It's good entertainment.
That's what it is.
I was thinking about everything is over analyze these days,
you know,
meaning is,
I feel the same way about stand up.
What's the message?
Where's he trying to say?
And then you're like,
it's just funny.
I like this show is just entertaining.
It's just good entertainment.
It is good.
Yeah.
The guy's got the weird mouth,
the lead character,
but I like him despite that.
Yeah.
And the white voters in it,
the comedian,
comedian,
he's great.
I love the therapist character.
I love his wife character.
She's,
she's a real fucking old school neighborhood.
Crazy.
I like that.
Um,
and so this episode we watched last night,
season two,
they introduced a nonbinary character.
Did nonbinary to other people who have been like,
yeah,
we were watching the show for months.
I know,
but we started,
we always when we might start on walking dead soon.
Yeah.
Maybe game of Thrones,
maybe soprano's we'll get into that wire.
I heard it's good.
We're going to try that soon.
Yup.
Good stuff.
But um,
it was,
it's a good day.
You look,
I like this act act was shut down.
I don't even know what to say.
I can't recall them.
An actor or is it actress?
No.
Actor.
Okay.
I like them.
I've seen them because they are really non-binary.
They really are.
And I've seen them on orange is the new black,
it's your pronoun.
They,
they are fantastic in that.
But uh,
it was cool.
It was interesting
to see how they,
they don't really address it.
Dan soders character is like,
oh I ordered you lunch.
I assumed you were Vegan and is really funny scene.
Yeah.
And then they go like,
well eventually yes they are making,
which is funny of course.
I mean,
yeah.
And they do do a good job with uh,
somebody else's like,
well she knew what she was talking about.
He's like,
they,
oh,
I didn't see that one.
Oh you bet you must have fallen asleep because they,
and then the person who's got like,
all right,
whatever.
Sure.
But before that,
so we were snuggling in bed with the dogs and everything and I wore a nice night
gown.
I thought it'd be kind of special.
It was nice.
So,
you know,
anyways,
we're snuggling and then you farted
and I let that one go.
I let slide.
I was like,
well,
you know,
fool me once.
And then the second fart rolled around
[inaudible]
why do you have to make eye contact with me when you play that drop?
It was kind of playing the sounds like when we read our book or Kid,
those sound books,
you're reading the text and I'm pushing the button
and then I,
I got up and I left because it was offensive.
The second one was so stinky.
And you really pushed,
it wasn't like an oopsie.
It was deliberate and I felt like you wanted me to smell it and get them
started.
But it occurred to me that because I've been smelling your farts for 12 years
now,
that I could probably guess
guests,
your farts in a lineup.
Like if there were,
I don't know if you really want to get that experiment going and going though.
I don't know if you want to ask like,
hey,
how about you guys,
you five guys fart here and uh,
I'll stand behind this door and then here's what we can do now.
I did these experiments in college where I had a roommate that would fart into
film containers and seal the container and then send the far across the country.
Somebody would open it.
You could smell the FARC.
I mean,
did you guys do that too?
My old roommate Kevin and he would mail fart to like his friends back home in
Seattle too.
They would smell it and it works.
They mailed me a fart once when I was studying in England and I got a Fart mail
to me.
And it does work.
They mailed me a from the states,
Shawna and Kevin.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's neat.
I mean I'm just saying that's one way we can do the experiment is that it just
be cool the mail someone a fart like that and have them open it and then they
just vomit because it smells.
If it catches you off guard,
it's really weird.
Yeah.
I mean I knew what it was cause we,
we'd done it as roommates.
Like it was a joke in the house.
They really does stay in there.
It does.
And and overseas,
I mean not traveled from the u s t two a England.
Unbelievable.
Really very impressive.
Now the key did today would be defined
the film container,
cause I don't even know if they,
so by them.
Yeah,
of course.
Like got Amazon.
We can get a bunch of film.
You go to the photo,
the photo lab that I went to,
they have to,
it has to be airtight.
You could ask them,
you know,
you could do go in there.
Do you guys have any discarded film canisters?
Good for like ceiling farts and see if they're like,
ah,
yeah,
you want to nail somebody apart.
Yeah.
That's what we sell these over here for a meal and farts to people.
Sure.
No problem.
I mean,
you have to admit that it's a pretty amazing discovery.
Like my old roommate,
Kevin,
discovered it randomly.
Yeah.
And it is pretty revolutionary if you think about it.
How else would you mail a fart?
No,
it's incredible.
It's incredible.
How else could you send the smell?
You could put it in one of those mason jars with like the real,
oh,
that's actually what the seal,
you know that kind.
We're used to pull the lever to seal it.
I know you're talking about decorative.
Yeah,
no.
Are Those air tight?
Yeah.
Now here's my thinking.
Uh,
scientists listening can verify or not.
The reason the film canister works so well is because you have less volume in
there.
Yeah.
There's less air.
So really preserves the essence of the fart.
Now my thinking is a mason jar.
It can be very large and maybe you're going to dilute the smell.
Mm.
With all the air molecules.
I have to point this out.
It just,
I just remember,
I don't want to forget.
Okay.
Paternal twins means identical twins.
See now I'm the last week when we were talking about it.
Yes,
we got some messages.
I looked it up and it's not commonly referred to as paternal.
No,
I know her fraternal or identical,
but there.
But technically paternal is identical dental meaning the egg splits into two.
Right,
right.
The same egg.
Right.
So making that point that when we were trying to figure out what that meant,
it's been clarified.
Okay.
Well yeah,
somebody wrote identical dicks are important.
Hey Hitler,
mommies.
I just wanted to share a story about twin penises with you.
I just had a Hawaiian family move in across the street from me.
The father invited me over to have a few beers with him.
He has twin sons and in the middle of our conversation he said,
I hope they have the same size dick or else one is going to steal the other
one's girlfriend due to having a larger penis.
My jaw dropped earlier that day.
You guys were having the very important question about twin dicks.
Sorry,
this doesn't answer the question,
but it's important we find out the answer.
Love always your Bali,
you're poly by flipper guy.
Wow.
Well,
this is one of those mysteries that we're going to continue exploring.
Never stop.
Never stop searching nine until justice is served.
You see that Dick Detectives,
uh,
graphics
in one lane.
You didn't see this.
Oh my God,
it's so fucking phenomenal.
I'm going to send it,
send the smell,
send this smell.
MMM.
Here.
I'll pull it up on the screen.
So just give me a second.
In the meantime,
uh,
Tom,
we've been getting a little pushback on a topic very popular and dear to our
hearts.
You know,
Danielle does zoely we know that Dasa.
She changed it to as a ds on Twitter.
Okay.
Danielle?
Yeah,
she writes a,
Hey,
Christina p Tom Sigora.
I know this is an inflammatory statement,
but I've been thinking about it.
Farts do push the shit out.
Oh,
we're going there again,
Huh?
I mean,
it's thought provoking and,
uh,
let's reopen the topic.
What's the explanation?
I mean we had a great explanation for the other,
for that Shit's push the FARCs out.
Right.
So why is she saying that the opposite though?
She just feels that way.
Oh,
case failing argument.
I mean the other person really laid out that we had it wrong this whole time.
And you're saying that someone said no,
it's the other way,
but there's no argument.
She said that she's been thinking about,
I guess what she's saying is intuitively it feels as though farts push the shit
as opposed to shits pushing the pharmacy counter intuitive that it sheds.
Put the push the far out.
It's counterintuitive.
It's not logical.
No,
it is logical,
but I feel it's far.
It's do push to shed.
So yeah,
but then how do you shit,
okay,
think about it.
Here's the thing.
Here's my case,
Yada is that,
how do I know I have to shit in the morning.
The forests are coming cause the shits are pushing the farts out.
But the farmers are also simultaneously bushing this shit out.
Oh No.
But then I can't fart without the sh.
I can't shit without the farts.
Okay.
Well,
I think we'll have to a table this have to agree to disagree.
Yeah.
We'll wait a little bit longer on this.
Um,
uh,
Bob Brown.
Uh,
but thank you for supporting the store.
There's all these,
uh,
we have the DJ dad mouth,
that black shirt people asked for that shirt and black,
the rub rub shirt.
Obviously he likes that.
Goes Up.
Cane has a new shirt.
Um,
big daddy Kane and I did together.
uh,
anyways,
and there's moose suit.
There's a two moose soup shirts.
So thanks for everyone.
I always want to say thank you for,
for getting them and uh,
hope you like to see,
hold on,
I have to Fart.
Like,
you know what maybe should to push the farts out because I can fart without
having,
yeah,
I think,
I think we're all good now.
I think we've covered all your thoughts and opinions on this and
no,
but think about it.
If I can fart without having to shit.
Yeah.
Then it truly is that shit's pushed the farts out.
That's far as don't have to push the shit out.
This is what I wanted to show you.
Look,
it's the state,
the Dick Detectives,
fat head comics.
Oh Wow.
Isn't that fantastic?
Amazing.
Like get her.
But this outline of the deck
that's so good deck here in the Dick Detectives.
Great.
It's really fun.
That's really fucking,
that had comics on Instagram and Twitter.
Thank you very much for the Dick Detectives.
Graphics don't,
don't,
yeah,
it's really great man.
I'm really impressed.
Do you want to hear some,
uh,
emails about deaf people?
Yeah.
Okay.
So last time you know,
the problem with this fucking Otterbox,
we asked to how blind people,
uh,
no.
Is it deaf people or blind people?
How they wake up?
Definitely.
Yeah.
Clock.
Uh,
this person writes in Bridget,
my college roommate was not deaf,
but would sleep through any alarm.
She bought an alarm made for deaf people.
It was a mat that slid under her mattress and would shake her whole bed at say,
at the set time.
I've always wondered about,
that's really interesting.
There are people out there that cannot wake up.
Isn't that amazing?
I know.
Um,
I remember my buddy Steve and high school,
we,
you know,
we would crash at each other's places all the time and the alarm could be next
to his head.
Oh,
full blast.
And I would be like,
I just look at this dude like,
and you can just go and start shaking him.
Sleeps right through it.
I don't understand that he's touched right.
I know.
I don't think so.
He's slow now.
He's just got a big head.
Yeah.
Um,
I know people like that.
I hate people like that.
I know.
And like Bernard
pick them up like a Saturday morning,
we'd have a,
you know,
they'd have the Ma,
you got to practice sometimes on Saturday.
So I drive over to his place.
I'm pounding on the door that's next to his bedroom,
pound,
pound.
And I could hear the alarm through the door.
So annoying Jane,
by the way,
my younger sister,
if she falls asleep on the couch at midnight and you're like,
oh,
go to bed,
you can,
you can take her.
You could drag her off the couch,
leave her head,
hang on the couch.
Her legs are on the couch,
still would wake up,
you can push or you can smack her in the face.
Nothing so crazy.
I don't understand how you could sleep that deeply.
I guess their neurological maybe there they shut down.
So completely more so than you know other people.
I don't know.
Yeah.
But I heard about us once we started asking,
people have come up to me at even at those shows and they said about,
uh,
shaking bed.
Okay,
well,
here's another one.
Uh,
we asked
Oh.
Dot.
[inaudible] hold on.
Another thing is people,
deaf people use flashing lights.
A doorbell ring would be a quick Ding Dong or an on off succession of flashing
lights at a baby.
Crying will be rapidly blinking.
Lights indicate wow.
Wow.
So like how do they get around the house and do more bells and stuff like that
they use.
Yeah.
But I guess you have to have those lights in the room,
obviously,
that you're in,
right?
Yeah.
Yes,
yes,
of course.
Yeah.
So do you put them everywhere?
I guess so.
Are the whole must blank?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Beats the shit out of me.
Anyway.
Here's another very thought provoking question about blind people that came in.
Corey from Judy,
Dork titties writes in,
Hey Hitler's,
how do blind people find the Braille signage in public places?
No Shit.
Right?
How the fuck did they find it?
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Dammit.
I mean there's sometimes it makes obvious sense like ATM because you're,
you're finding out where's the ATM and you know,
you,
you're directed towards it by somebody and then once you get there,
you can read the Braille.
But
I dunno,
I mean that's,
that's interesting,
right?
Yeah.
I guess your guide and then maybe have a guide and the guide is,
I told you,
this is why he goes about the a,
the time I was in,
it was in New York and uh,
in Ju Dork titties and there was a blind guy across the street going like this,
waving his hand over his head.
And he started to do it more and more aggressively.
And I guess what it was,
what he was doing was he was signaling that he needed somebody to walk him
across the street,
but he wasn't,
he wasn't nice about it at all.
So when I went up to him,
he goes,
God dammit doing it for 10 fucking minutes.
And then like I walked across the street with him,
you know,
he's like,
God.
And then like when we got to the other side,
he didn't say like thanks.
He was just like mother fucker.
And then he just kept walking because I think that light didn't have the uh,
yeah.
So he just stood there and I was like,
I mean,
I was hesitant to a pro.
I was,
I don't know what this fucking gun,
crazy person waiting,
waiting,
waiting for someone to help him.
Did she give him a rub?
Rub,
rub to thanks.
So do you want me to kiss you on the penis or anything like that?
And he was like,
yeah.
He's like,
that's why I've been waiting for,
for 10 minutes to sharpen the knife.
You have to,
yeah.
So you have to do sometimes,
how's it the comedy store?
This weekend and I took pictures of people and I was talking to fans in the
hallway and people will listen to the show and everybody was like,
[inaudible] you are the personality champ because where's Tom Right now?
He's not even at the comedy store.
Taking pictures.
Absolutely sealed your fate because hundreds of people and punchline Sacramento
where like,
I'll tell you one thing,
Christina didn't meet us
after this show and you want to know something?
I'll be a hundred percent honest here.
Yeah.
The reason I did not,
yeah.
They have metal detectors for people going in.
So I was like,
I'm kinda scared honestly.
And I don't think that our fans are,
uh,
you know,
gun wielding lunatics.
But I was like,
if they're fucking making these people go through metal detectors,
I mean,
you know,
it just spooked me a,
I don't know,
but I still,
I was spooked.
You were spook,
you know,
bed really.
I swear sac down,
Huh?
I swear
I had a guy walk by me and he had that mid day drunk swag,
you know,
he was like,
I could see him walking up and he was like,
I could see he was like talking shit to nobody,
but you know how alcohol will give you a little more.
And he was like shit.
And then as he walked by me,
he was like,
I was born in this city and I'll put my foot up your mother fucking ass.
And I was like,
okay.
And then as he walked by me,
he turned around,
he goes,
come and do it.
The other new you.
I was like this dude,
that means that's some serious shit.
That's like an old school thing to say to you know,
come in as a 20 year old reference in a way that by the club.
No,
this was downtown.
The mattress store and up buy the mattress store.
That location is weird.
That's what I'm saying.
And that's another reason I'm kind of like scared to meet people.
Yeah.
Because I don't like to locate the mattress stores.
Weird.
Also,
I had a lot of weird experiences and the hotel,
like I feel like there was a lot of just zombies weirdos around.
I was like,
I don't know.
It's a weird area,
but at the show you should feel right.
Like I said,
I trust her mom's house fans,
but there were other people at the shows,
not just mommy's,
you know,
like you're one of those Weirdos motherfuckers go stab me or something.
I didn't know that you,
I mean it's different being a woman I guess.
Hell yeah.
It was also a different,
having any super sour personality.
Do you know?
So maybe that was it.
I don't have a sour personality.
That's terrible.
Yeah,
you do.
Look who's fun.
First of all,
I'm fully hydrated.
I have to Fiji water.
Okay.
Super Fun APP is fun.
Guatemala Mug that our nanny got us.
I mean,
got me because I'm fun.
I like to have fun.
Where's your fun Guatemalan Mug?
She didn't get you one because she knows that your personality doesn't
appreciate fun.
Silly.
Oh my God.
I have an update on bitsy.
So she's been dragging her ass,
scooting,
and we took her and they checked her anal glands.
She's been on the antibiotics and everything and turns out today she's got our
little rashy on her vulva,
them on her vulva.
So now we have to put cream on our dogs,
vulva three times a day and she's wearing a cone so she can't lick it poor
little.
She's taking three different antibiotics just to make sure we kill whatever it
is that's bothering her badge.
We have to put the cream on our dogs badge three times a day
and now she keeps trying to lick on it and she can't cause the cones on
a lot of Gypsies gotten mad that Tom Segura said the word Gypsy on television.
I didn't know Gypsy's had time to watch TV between pick pocketing and scamming
society.
All right.
That is true.
It is true.
Yeah.
I said Gypsy on Conan,
you'll will,
you said say Gyn.
I said,
see again,
but then I translated,
you know,
I said,
I've been teaching my son what my wife teaches me.
You can again,
them don't know had to go in and I said,
you know,
yes,
no rotten gypsy and uh,
whatever.
It was just like a throwaway to to set up the song.
The Hungarian song.
Yeah.
First of all,
Hungarians,
you were right.
You're like,
you're going to have him Gary,
that's come out now.
Yeah.
They love it.
Comes up.
And he's like,
I enjoyed your show.
I understand what you said.
I go,
you understand what I said?
Gone.
Then all your Hungarian,
I think it was a meeting us.
He goes,
oh,
and I got good vice than Bozeman.
And he goes,
aw.
And then his friends are like,
what?
He's saying?
What he's saying?
He goes,
he's not nice
on the corner.
He did it go,
you did a really good accent.
And he did it well I should say not good.
He looked like a rock biter too.
Hardcore.
Hardcore guys.
It's funny.
Hungarians are very,
very stoked to be Hungarian.
Yeah.
Cause there's like five of us on the planet.
So we're very proud of it.
Yeah,
I understand.
Is nobody who's on gear.
Well also it's about if we are Hungarian or from that part of the world and
you're here.
Right.
Cause obviously it's crazy.
This is,
this is a long way from home.
So I would,
I mean it makes sense if you're like,
oh are you Bulgarian?
Me Too.
Like that's something to get excited about.
You know,
Lithuanian,
Romanian,
those are all things that
Transylvania and there's a very small community.
You don't see it that much.
Just see,
no,
I'm 100% uh,
genetically Hungarian,
like all the way.
They know it's free.
We did that.
Whatever genetic testing and yeah,
like I go back to the whatever Paleo from the,
the big tip patrol.
You definitely,
my tits are big all the way back generations,
generations of test.
There was,
it was the whole,
the whole,
the map of the world.
All the region was one.
Yeah.
Are All on my ancestry.
It's pretty nuts.
I'm more diverse.
You are diverse,
but it's crazy.
And now I'm responsible for bringing my lineage to this part of the world.
Or my parents were Rad.
That's true.
No,
I am.
Cause I had the sun.
We got it.
We have a little half hung go.
Boy He is totally half hung.
Go tough.
Yeah.
Yes he was.
I don't like naps.
I like work.
Wow.
Cause your first words,
I'd say guide.
Speaking of that part of the world,
do you want to hear an accent?
It's pretty interesting to see if you can decipher what's being said.
Oh boy,
how you doing?
Hey you got a someday
we'll back at pier nine.
Well it's not really fair because I do think there's a little bit of
drunkenness.
Wait with WHO and mental element with this guy.
Well it was submitted.
They said,
ah,
you guys know accents so well.
Again,
it's,
it's also nonsensical because he's drug and probably schizophrenia.
I don't know about your diagnosis.
I don't support it.
Um,
I'm saying if he may have had a drink yet today or maybe the day before he had a
drink and he's just about to enjoy his cigarette.
It's possible.
But I don't think that,
let's just go back to what he's saying and not focus on your root diagnosis.
So let's see here.
Okay.
Clearly the first man says,
Hey,
Dan,
how you doing?
Yeah,
I got that part.
You got that part down a Silva.
He said [inaudible]
good for nothing.
For nothing.
Got Done.
Yeah.
Huh?
No.
Wooly mcateer is Kwan.
Oh,
wine mammoth.
Really?
Mcafee racketeering.
Kwon.
That's it.
The goddamn room.
Yeah.
Beirut Goddamn roosters.
And then,
uh,
say that Sunday.
So Leslie Day.
Okay.
Lovely Day.
Excuse me,
the old one.
Yeah.
Crap,
crap,
blah,
blah.
He sounded like Cosby a little loud and reminded me of that amazing song.
Um,
do you remember where is it?
Uh,
when we did the,
what was it,
the Irvine show?
Yes.
One of the songs is the vocal fry champ,
but they use,
they use the,
um,
the drunk guy,
I think he's also Irish.
She's like,
yeah.
That was like,
yeah,
this guy.
Ah,
it's
amazing.
Um,
that's a gaping dad at the vocal fry song.
I have to say.
We got,
you know,
every once in a while you get so much.
Um,
so many replies,
responses and excitement about songs that Matt Mercer Song from last week.
People flipped out.
Yeah,
it was good.
Really good.
I realized too,
I was like,
man,
I know he's made other songs for us.
And uh,
he made,
let me see.
What is it?
Vocal fry he made.
Uh,
what is it?
It's the river song.
Yeah.
Look at the river.
Remember that one?
You spit when you heard the song the first time he made this song.
Ooh.
Alright,
here we go.
I'm going over the new bridge.
Here we go.
Does Matt Mercer also?
That's amazing.
It was so funny.
Yeah.
God I doubt is ridiculous.
Hey,
wait a minute.
Stop the presses.
Oh,
what,
what do you have a dental update?
Oh my God.
I have the biggest dental update,
but,
but before I even get into the dental update,
let me remind people,
now that we're pulling out those songs,
every time I log in to Facebook,
I'll see Facebook,
Facebook,
cause I see hundreds,
I'm not exaggerating,
hundreds of unread messages.
We don't do it.
We don't,
we'll send emails and they go check out.
We only access things for the show from our g mail account.
Yeah.
So if you have a song,
if you have a clip,
if you have a story,
if you have a message for Fargo,
you'd want to send them the canister,
all of that.
It's your mom's podcast@gmail.com that is,
there's no house in the email address.
Your Mom's podcast@gmail.com.
I just want it to make it clear.
If you've been sending stuff on Facebook.
We don't,
we don't check it out.
Social media.
All right.
Hi.
It's so big.
I can't believe we forgot it.
I know.
So it's been a,
I
will say I've been pretty good.
I've been pretty good lately with dental care.
Uh,
this is the,
I went seven months,
you know,
he's supposed to do every six.
Yeah.
So seven months ago I had my teeth cleaned.
I went back for a cleaning,
but I also scheduled a in house whitening treatment.
Hold on.
Before we get there,
how
was your report card?
What was your gum score?
Oh,
I was,
uh,
just as solid as last time.
Yeah,
no,
what's that?
Okay.
And he was just hitting your numbers.
Let's hear them.
Or I forget,
I forget which number is cause I always hear at one to two,
two like I'm always really good.
Yeah,
that's what he says.
You're probably like eight and actually you want to know the truth.
You can call him and ask him this.
You said it best set of teeth I've seen in a year.
Peeling.
Yeah,
that's an inaccurate because he said that about my teeth and I was there less
than a year ago.
Thank you very much.
So I'm the teeth champion.
He,
there's so much better than yours.
If we,
if we did teeth champ,
I'm definitely the teeth.
Lilo's disagree.
Disagree.
He's like,
you have dog teeth.
No,
my God,
my teeth are so much better than yours.
Always have those canine problems.
What canine tooth file down all the time.
Your teeth are sharp and,
and Jag like Jag had tic tacs.
Look how white they are anyways.
Barely can see them though because of your big lips and facial hair.
Are you done?
Go ahead.
So I went there.
The cleaning was,
was fun and fine and it wasn't fun,
but painless.
The cleaning was okay.
No problem.
Yeah,
nope.
No blood,
no good.
It was,
I was all good
when they're done.
I was like,
oh,
that was actually pretty quick.
Then they go and now we're going to do the whitening and man,
so first they put this thing to give like so you can give blowjobs like it opens
your mouth up really big.
And uh,
I posted that picture on Instagram who's did real well?
People really like it.
Um,
and then they put,
they did not want to get,
we'll give you braces.
They tried to embarrass,
separate your,
your lips from touching.
Yeah.
Where your teeth are going to be.
Then they put a protective gel on your gum line.
Hmm.
Um,
and then after that,
then they put this fucking hydrochloric acid on your teeth to start bleeding and
then they do multiple rounds for an hour.
So the first round went by and I'm like,
oh,
la.
I had my,
thank God I had the headphones,
I was listening to a podcast.
Um,
then I go mother Fucker,
second round I started,
oh,
I go like this,
um,
to wipe something on my lip and my,
my finger touches it and did.
She goes,
you're gonna burn your hand.
And I'm like,
okay.
So she wiped my hand.
We'll a little bit,
got on my lip,
started burning my lip.
So I had to write on my phone,
my lip is burning,
and then she took a cloth and she wiped my lip by the third round.
Um,
I was definitely feeling burning in my gums and a a little bit on my tongue.
Oh God.
That's the worst.
He did a thing where she sprayed into the gum line and then sucked it out right
away.
Yeah.
That helps.
But after that final round,
I was like,
this is burning pretty bad.
You know,
man,
that night I had a like shooting pains in my teeth.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you're burning enamel,
the layers of enamel off your teeth,
but it is worth it.
It's worth it.
I mean,
your
teeth look so much better now.
I'm so happy for you.
They're not buttery yellow.
Again.
People don't really see your teeth a lot because you don't smile much cause
you're not a good personality.
You don't have a good personality.
Yeah.
Um,
so I don't know if it's totally lost money,
you know what I mean?
But it's good that it's there.
The teeth are white.
Appreciate you.
Appreciate you,
appreciate your thoughts.
It's been nicer looking at you.
Tell you that.
Yeah.
I bet it is.
Um,
you're so mean to your parents.
You're always like,
can I pay for you guys to do it?
Please?
It's true.
I wanted to,
do you think your dad would do it?
Your Dad needs it.
Can they treat dad now?
Like if you were to go,
I don't know if they would actually treat him because I remember when she said,
we're going to your tie your teeth whitening.
I go,
yeah,
she goes,
show me your teeth.
And she held up like this,
all these little teeth on a,
on a,
uh,
I guess on a,
what's it called?
On a thing.
Uh,
like a stick like yeah.
To see all the different shades that your teeth aren't going to be as.
She goes,
okay,
you're in this shade.
And she goes,
you're lucky it's um,
yellow and not gray.
She goes,
if it's gray,
this won't work.
She goes with yellow on it.
Like a yellow hue means we can,
you can lift the color.
She goes grey.
We can't do it.
Interesting.
So you're saying that your dad's gray,
I think a lot of old people are gray.
Yeah.
Right.
That's rotten.
Yeah.
And that,
that's probably what it adds to the dad mouth is the grayness of the teeth.
It's probably the bacteria,
the dying,
decaying teeth in your head or making your mouth stink bad.
Yeah.
So lots of his and your gums are probably old and stinky too.
It's just probably the age of your mouth that makes you dads get dad mail and
just what kind of maintenance are you doing?
Like anything else.
So you taking care of it,
got to maintain,
you got to maintain.
Yeah.
I don't think your dad flosses would you say that he flosses no,
no,
no.
And probably reluctantly goes,
you know,
to get things done like,
yeah,
teeth and gum care.
I'm sure.
Oh God.
Got to go there again.
Like I went last year.
I know you didn't,
well,
I went two years ago like that.
Does your mom floss?
[inaudible] I'm sure she doesn't.
Yeah,
that's my guess.
I Dunno.
Maybe like she's the kindness,
like,
oh,
this is annoying.
I just had,
corn is bothering me.
Let's get it out.
Most people,
I like that.
I say that's when most people floss.
That's,
but that's the only time I,
I haven't seen her.
We were like,
oh,
I got floss.
I'm going to bed.
My sisters are actually really good at dental care.
Both Jane's got great teeth.
I remail always remember Maria like flossing all the time.
It's got great teeth too.
Yup.
Very High Joes who are good at it,
but the folks not
so much.
My name is Daniel Pauly,
Etsy,
and I'm a cat consulting advice.
500 individual clients and their cats.
So this asshole,
wait,
it gets better.
Today we visited bill.
Bill has three cats.
One is urinating on bill while he was sleeping.
Actually surrendered to my advice and ask a cat permission for what he wants.
That's the kind of advice that's going to get if your cat is fucking pissing on
you or your dog,
I'd say that's a sign of severe behavioral problems of the cat and the cat does
not respect you.
This guide,
as I see it this way,
he thinks,
wait till you hear the language he uses.
I teach clients
love.
These cats are trying to tell
I am the voice.
Is this the fundamental difference?
The divide,
if you will,
between cat and dog people.
Is that the cat people?
Armando,
you were talking about how we're on the brink of civil war in this country,
but what were you saying?
No,
no,
no.
The very important stuff going on.
We don't talk about that.
Uh,
the very important divide between cat and dog people is that people who,
who love cats really love being treated poorly and they,
they see themselves as submissive to the cats dog people,
aren't we?
I don't think.
Where is that?
That way?
No,
you have to be dominant.
That's what he said.
He wants him to his human clients to be better,
uh,
to be better slaves and cat.
But I'm saying my best friend's a cat person and she's always talking about,
you know,
the cat's being a jerk and that,
but they are submissive to the cats needs.
It's different in the dog world,
you have to ignore door,
the dominant dominant.
You have to otherwise the dog,
they have free reign and it's not healthy for them.
I don't like it.
I'm just saying it's two different worlds.
I'm not judging it.
Troll,
they need rules and boundaries and guidelines.
Cats set the tone of the house and then you and they're free roam.
Yeah.
I think it's harder to discipline a cat.
How do you even,
I've had cats growing up.
You don't,
you just don't.
Right.
You just do what they do and you adapt.
Yeah,
exactly.
They fuck up your house and Piss on you while you sleep,
piss on your face and you're just like,
well that's what my kitty does.
He finally asked for permission to,
yeah.
Walk me through this.
Is there more?
Oh,
there's more.
I love it.
My concentration is finding out what's going on with the cap to not only
understand the body language,
but the emotions.
Oh,
there's your favorite favorite staying right there.
that's some good stuff right there.
He's monitor.
See,
my favorite would be,
he goes right.
See He's,
um,
he's upset about when you leave without telling him.
And I go,
um,
I think he's happy right here.
And then he goes,
no,
he's not.
How do you know that?
Right.
How do you not know that what you're interpreting as his actual
thing out or anxiety is in his joy?
Did,
is there anything as Diet?
Did you read his diary when he went to bed last night?
He has tattoos of cats on his body.
He wears cat apparel.
The guy is an expert.
Okay,
sure.
My experience comes from working in the animal shelter system.
It's hard work.
My last job,
because I love the people and I love cats.
I wonder if he knows our friend that also works in the animal.
Should probably should ask her.
Yeah.
Was like,
Hey,
do you know this clown that does a cat consulting?
Well,
my friend also loves cats too.
She might,
they might be a match made in heaven actually might be perfect for you.
Um,
you can learn a lot.
It's kind of vocal fry cats.
They live in Wilmington.
Here we go.
I'd say all dog owners,
they're stupid.
Here's their emotions.
I'm happy to see you.
I'm getting upset.
Let's be best friends.
I'm interested.
I'm crazy about you feeling loving.
I'm worried,
Huh?
Oh,
cats.
Cats.
Sure lands to and I think that's what a lot of people don't necessarily do.
Cats live in the meow.
Oh,
that's cute.
Cats live in them.
Yeah.
I love that.
Of course you do.
They live in them.
Yeah.
Right?
Press pause.
Hey,
do you think we're going to get a cat soon?
That'd be fun.
No,
come on.
You can't let it be an outdoor cat.
I'm not against it as a species,
but I'm allergic to them and we suck.
Yeah.
I like having cat around cancer fund.
What does this person was saying?
Catch everything.
I know too much about my dad preferences
with all the talk of Tom and not wanting to know what gets Topdog hard.
I can top that.
God.
After my dad's second marriage ended,
we live together just the two of us.
Eventually we got fairly comfortable with each other and he started dating
again.
One night he came home from a date.
I asked him the usual,
so how'd it go?
He smiled and then proceeded to shove two of his fingers.
He just used a stir.
His dates paint up to my nose.
Oh whoa.
Now she's my stepmom.
Uh,
keep it high and tight.
Storm and Nasty as oh fuck
storm.
That could be a guy or a girl.
Perfect show for this.
Yeah.
That's really,
I don't know why parents don't understand that even though they're adult,
everybody's an adult.
The child being an adult as well.
Yeah.
We don't want to know things about your life.
I have a friend named who is living with his dad and his dad fucks.
Yeah,
the door open.
Yes.
He told me about that.
And then he was like,
Dad,
please can you shut the door when you fuck your girlfriend?
And he was like your dogs in.
And he said,
the dog gets nervous if I shut the door.
She was like,
I don't care man.
I don't want to hear you.
Fuck.
Don't you love his dad was just like,
what is your deal?
It's your problem.
The dads are narcissists who don't even think about the children's feelings or
anything,
right?
Why?
Why should your friend,
uh,
have a right to say anything but don't you love when people have lame excuses
for stuff like that?
Like,
well,
the dog,
I have to traumatize my son by fucking,
uh,
in front of him,
which I could close the door.
The dog,
the dog,
you asshole.
You're just an asshole.
He's a dog.
He's a p one fucking
stupidest reason.
Another email came in.
Do Blind people dream?
Listen,
if so,
do they dream in pictures,
smells or touches?
Gosh,
let's see.
That's a good question too.
Well,
I dunno.
I feel like it's obvious that they dream,
they dream,
but do they dream the same way that sighted people do because we see things?
How did they seen her mind's eye?
Well,
they have a vivid imagination,
I'm assuming,
right?
I don't know if you're blind.
Can you tell?
I mean,
but here's the thing,
what you describe would it be,
you know what I mean?
How do they know that they're seeing things differently than we do in our mind's
eye?
They don't know.
Unless you've been had your sight and then lost the right.
If you were born blind,
how do they know?
How do we,
how do we now trucks all day when your dreams are like fucking psychedelic?
Showdowns I love it.
No,
I don't.
I don't want to know what,
how you would describe what you see in your dreams.
Oh,
here's an email that came in about,
uh,
playing against disabled kids.
Last week I talked about a,
in football,
when we beat the deaf school,
it said,
hearing you talk about playing the deaf because of football sparked when you,
my classic memories from Childhood,
I am from Indiana.
We're basketball is life and in grade school I was playing against a team that
had a kid with a nub for a left arm.
I had to apprehensively guard him and immediately wanted to jump off a building.
When my super intense competitive dad yells from the stance,
make them go left with a whole gym to hear classic.
Just thought I would share.
Thanks for the most entertaining podcasts out there.
You make my 10 hour work day.
Go quickly keeping it high and tight bow.
Thanks Bo.
Yeah,
I remember playing in those little league games,
uh,
against a few nubs too.
Yeah,
there was always a,
in the little rec league teams,
they always had like a kid,
you know,
missing a hand or something.
Like in basketball there was some drug in the fifties I think that mothers were
taking,
I had,
I had a teacher in college who had the baby arm thing too and it was from some
drug.
They gave her money in football.
By the way,
I saw,
I've seen it on the news.
I'm sure people have seen this on the news.
There's this clip or you know,
with,
with social media,
it's made its rounds these days of this guy who played in high school game with
no legs flow.
He's just like,
he has little nub legs and he would waddle out there and actually play football.
How did he,
did he have like a machine,
like a wheelchair apparatus?
No,
seriously.
He would just on whatever legs did happen,
I think he had like,
uh,
like half arms full arms either.
And so he would play on the line and they would,
you know,
would just go out.
Uh,
it was,
I mean,
that was amazing to see that this kid wanted to do that that badly.
Yeah,
Dude.
Well,
if there's a will,
there's a way.
Yeah.
And I guess now to a technology they can,
you know,
maybe you can build things to help some.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't think he could do that in this particular case,
but I'm saying like other stuff.
Yeah.
That's cool.
That's pretty nice.
Nice.
Um,
what's it called when you want to burp vomit.
Oh,
please.
I don't want to hear this topic.
My girlfriend's,
Suzanne and I were intrigued by new vocabulary when you try to shit,
but only a fart.
My favorite is impostor,
which is a good one.
And then booster.
Yes,
I like that one a lot,
but while we were hugging ourselves the orgasm,
we were wondering why there's no word for when you try to Burp,
but you accidentally bump.
There is a word we propose the word Europe.
No verb.
No.
Also what if you cough and then vomit.
That's called the comments.
Stop it.
I know that mommy,
Tina loves her vomit,
so this will be helpful.
Love John and Suzanne.
Now being the,
the metaphor they,
I am.
Stop it.
I know the word.
It is called a birth ball.
A birth when you go to Burp,
but you vomit.
It is a birth and I haven't had a birth and several years,
but as a child had several bursts.
I Dunno.
For some reason childhood there is always,
you're always pushing out burps and so you'd birth,
yeah,
that happens,
right?
Yeah.
I hated barfing.
That was the worst because I need to remember,
need to have to take a sip of like cactus cooler or Dr Pepper.
Yeah.
Took me out.
I know I'm really on top of it.
I had to get those fingers ready.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're back.
No we're not and I don't trust you and why don't you trust me the minute I put
these headphones on,
you're going to play another barf clip.
I know you.
I won't quote.
You look so much like Robin Williams when you smile,
you always say that more like patch Adams though.
I don't know why I don't look like patch Adams.
Oh well I do know I knew it.
I can fucking hear it.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
You're the worst.
Yeah,
I'm not going to stop it.
I can hear it in the headphones stall.
Okay.
Did I tell you the email that this girl wrote in on wild back?
No.
I'm not going to put these on.
If you play barf clips,
your trigger finger is hot.
Let me see your hands.
Put your hands up.
Okay.
Anyways,
there is a girl who wrote in cause she knows I'm in a metaphor.
Yeah and does that what is called a metaphor he met to phobia to EMS is to throw
up e m e t.
O that I meant to phobia and she said there's a pill you can take that will
paralyze your stomach so that you don't vomit.
Have you taken it now?
Did you get it?
Yeah,
you do have it.
Well cause I read about it and like let's say you had the stomach flu or
something.
It's just spasms of the stomach muscle.
It's not necessary to vomit.
I know what you're doing and I find some sneaky,
sneaky.
There's something sneaky happened.
You think I'm fucking Nudie to you dude,
dude,
I know your farts in a lineup.
I know what you're doing.
You know it's not,
there's nothing over here like that.
There isn't.
There's nothing on this like that.
I promise.
I swear this one doesn't have it.
This one doesn't have it.
This one has
that
better watch out.
I'm just saying this one doesn't have that.
Do you want me to touch your penis then?
Don't play anymore.
Pew Clips.
Come on.
Don't ruin the fun for everybody.
Fun.
Do you know how much the audience likes when you've made my,
they messaged me about the topic and they like it.
That's terrible.
They like my suffering.
Yeah,
they like it.
They react.
It's a genuine reaction.
That's why they like it.
They want to see genuine stuff.
You know,
here the worst.
Okay.
I'm shutting it down and I'm sure they lost all my trust.
Babe.
That one was an accident.
I didn't mean to do that.
I didn't mean to.
I'm sorry about that.
So,
but it's over now.
No,
it's not.
You're lying.
No,
it's over.
It is over.
Um,
you want to see this woman get really excited about eating an ice cream Sundae?
I guess a new Sunday came out.
She got Barf it up.
No,
she doesn't Barf it up,
but she gets really excited and she's alone and she's just like,
God damn,
this fucking tastes good.
It's like,
here,
look
[inaudible]
it's,
it's a bacon Sundae.
I like how she matched her shirt to the decor of that restaurant is pretty cool.
You're full on purple.
There's a lot of things going on with her.
[inaudible]
what is happening if we can be honest,
she shouldn't be eating that.
She should not be having the Sunday.
The Bacon Sundae.
She's retarded.
You don't share dairy?
Wow.
I mean that's my new favorite.
I feel like I'm going to appreciate that clip a lot the next time I see it like
I felt like I like it a lot already.
I felt that way before.
Like you know when you've been alone and you felt that way when you're eating,
especially with food.
Who was one of those things where sometimes you go like,
especially if you're alone and just don't want to be like you got to try it,
buy it and I have been several times I've wanted to do the exact same thing.
You ever want to do this?
If there's buyers,
this is so cool.
It's La.
That's La for you.
Thinking about moving to La Jesus.
That's one of the things you can run into here and in Los Angeles,
things aren't well for her.
She kind of reminds me a little bit of it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Female.
That's so weird.
That was the girl.
Fuck me in my ass,
man.
I love that.
Which is howling smashing the car.
Can we hear the homeless guy?
That's a good one.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Shit,
shit,
Shit.
Shit
man.
Okay.
I really does it.
And what is the homeless homeless,
homeless guy gets raped by gay goes.
Yes.
They know.
They gotta take it down from a lot of places,
I think both for its title and content.
Yeah.
Is it because the title was homeless man raped by a gay guy,
which is a really clever why?
Yeah.
It does a lot of places.
She just so you know,
the lady we just played is laying on the hood of a car.
Just ain't fuck you Jesus.
Fuck me.
Jesus.
Yeah.
And pretending to be fucked and humping the car.
Giving a blow job.
Yeah.
It's a lot.
We're just mocking people that need help right now.
Fuck me.
Yeah,
no,
it's interesting.
Pretty good.
Um,
is there anything else you need,
Jane?
Anything else?
I think I got it all and this episode.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Jeez us.
Um,
yeah,
thank you guys.
As always for listening to the show and,
um,
and we'll be back soon with another episode and we might have a guest in here
next time and we'll be looking forward to seeing you at the live shows coming up
and on the road.
Of course,
as we keep touring,
oh,
this,
uh,
if you listen to this right away,
this Friday I'm doing a Joe Rogan episode 1000 the Nanas.
Is that a thousand?
That's so crazy,
dude.
It's myself and Jose,
Coco Diaz and Joe.
And then that night we're going to do a celebration show at the comedy store.
Super Fun.
That's going to be a lot of fun.
That's a big show.
You guys should get your tickets.
I Dunno if it's sold out.
It's sold out in like three minutes.
That's crazy.
But the podcast will be fun to look podcast.
The podcast will be very fun to listen to.
Um,
so check it out.
And again,
uh,
thank you for listening.
We'll see you next time.
Bye Jane.
Here's the rub rub song by Dj boy butter.
Thanks mommies.
I follow Americans.
There's a one ministry,
not the assault in this country,
and that is where all the comments,
Brown,
Brown coal stuff each day.
Dude.